It's great to welcome to the program today.
Rutger Bregman, who is a historian and also
author of Humankind A Hopeful History and
the Bestselling Utopia for Realist.
You may also recognize him from such viral
moments as that time.
He said the thing about taxes at Davos.
And when Tucker Carlson flipped out on him
and tried not to air it.
Rucker, great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me, David.
So to begin with, a hopeful history, humankind.
I'm interested in this because particularly
right now, there are many people who who maybe
don't have the most optimistic perspective
on humanity and end on Homo sapiens.
So what is your source of general optimism
about humanity?
The book is really about a sort of silent
revolution that has taken place in science
within, I'd say, the last 15 to 20 years.
So what has happened is that scientists from
very diverse disciplines, anthropologists,
sociologists, psychologists, you name it,
have moved from maybe a little bit cynical
view of human nature to a much more positive,
hopeful view of human nature.
So in the book, I'm just sort of describing
this whole process and trying to point this
out, because what I discovered is that often
these scientists don't even know it from each
other.
Right.
There was one psychologist who at one point
during my research said to me when I told
her about, you know, stuff that is happening
in biology, she said, oh, my God, it's happening
there as well.
So I just wanted to to let people know that
this has been going on and it may be a source
for hope as well.
How do you make the case that human beings
are sort of fundamentally good to the extent
that that's kind of definable, actionable
term?
Well, I wouldn't say that people are fundamentally
good, right, where we're clearly not angels.
Yes.
What I would say is that what you assume in
other people is often what you get out of
them.
Right.
So if you assume that most people are selfish
and they'll start designing your institutions
around that idea, you know, your schools,
your marketplaces, everything you're doing
in society, then that's what you get out of
people.
Right.
So what you assume is what you get.
I think this is actually the defining idea
of what we call neo liberalism.
Right.
Which is basically people are selfish and
deal with it and design everything around
it.
I think it has sort of produced the kind of
people that the theory presuppose.
And I think we can turn it around.
And in the book, I try to give a lot of examples
of, for example, schools or or even organizations
or even prisons that work with this sort of
different kind of view of human nature and
then get some pretty interesting results as
well.
Well, that's what's so interesting about it,
which is, as you point out, if if you take
an economic perspective, if you believe people
are fundamentally greedy, then design an economic
system around that.
And it has major implications that are difficult
to undo even if people aren't fundamentally
greedy.
Yeah, if you look at evolutionary psychology,
if you look at social, etc., it every one
of the systems we've designed is based around
some of these core ideas.
So the implications are actually not just
theoretical and trivial.
The very real it's quite revolutionary idea.
So for first it may sound like, oh, this guy
has written some nice happy clappy book about
how human beings are friendly.
No, actually the implications are really revolutionary
because, you know, if we cannot trust each
other, then we need them right to keep us
in check.
Then we need the CEOs and the managers and
the bankers and the monarchs and the generals
and you name it.
Then we need those in power.
Then we need hierarchy.
If actually most people are pretty decent
and can be trusted.
Then we can move to a radically different
society.
You know, that is much more egalitarian where
people have the freedom to make their own
choices.
Suddenly, all kinds of things become possible.
That initially were not possible at all.
At what sort of level of focus do you think
is the right one to make these observations
about humanity?
And I'll give you an example of what I mean.
You could take, for example, the Kitty Genovese,
the story of 1964 and the bystander effect
and use that to extrapolate about human nature.
Or you could say, hey, you know what?
Over time, war has become less and less common.
Right.
These are very different levels of focus,
which may get you to different conclusions
about human nature.
Where do you think we should start evaluating
what human nature is?
Well, I think you need to look all these things
in the book.
I start with a very old theory with a Western
culture, which is the idea of.
Mere theory.
Right.
And the idea goes like this.
Supposedly civilization is only a thin veneer.
And as soon as something happens, say, a war
or a natural disaster or you ship wreck on
an island, then supposedly people reveal their
true selves.
And, you know, they show that they're really
animals and they're selfish.
If you look, for example, the news coverage
of natural disasters.
It's pretty much always like this.
It's always veneer theory.
You know, the news is full of stories about
looting and violence and plunder, you know,
the hawk and the horrible stories.
But actually, what sociologists have known
basically since the 1960s is that what you
get every single time after a natural disaster
is an explosion of cooperation.
People really working together.
A great example is what happened after Katrina
in the US.
Rebecca Solon has written a fantastic book
about this, A Paradise Built Now.
But there are many other examples around the
globe.
So it's really the opposite of Viniar theory.
But still, this theory is so deeply entrenched
in our culture.
You know, the idea that deep down we're all
selfish.
It goes back all the way to the Asian Greeks.
You find it with the Christian church fathers.
You know, the idea that we're all born as
sinners.
Even the Enlightenment philosophers.
David, you Adam Smith, I think you could argue
that the US itself was sort of founded on
the idea that people are selfish.
If you read some of the texts of the founding
fathers, John Adams, for example, he wrote
an essay that said all men would be tyrants
if they could, or James Madison, who said,
you know, ambition must be made to counteract
ambition.
You know, let's let's be real.
Let's assume that most people are selfish.
So often when people say, oh, you've got to
be a realist, they say, well, don't be too
idealistic.
Right.
Otherwise, you're naive.
And so I think that the larger project here
is sort of to try and redefine what it means
to be a realist.
Is that actually the realistic scientific
position these days is to sort of conclude
that actually human beings have evolved to
cooperate?
And there's actually this process in our evolutionary
history that biologists call survival the
friendliest, which is very much the opposite
of what I had always thought.
What role in this analysis does the idea of
a sort of multi-layer evolutionary selection
have to play the idea that an individual being
greedy within a group that cooperates may
may be a more relevant way to look than simply
humans are individually greedy or not greedy?
Well, there certainly are different theories
right now within biology, right, whether you
should look at evolution on the individual
level or on the group level.
And there's a lot of scientific debate going
on there.
And to be honest, I don't really have a big
prefere position here.
I think sort of the more important takeaway
of, you know, developments within biology
of the past couple of years, say 15 to 20
years.
Is that actually biologists have discovered
this process of what they call survival of
the friendliest.
Right.
So for thousands of years, it was actually
the friendliest among us who had the most
kids.
You know, imagine Donald Trump in pre-history.
It's an impossibility.
You know, he wouldn't have survived for long.
People would have liked him, wouldn't want
to cooperate with him and would have expelled
him from the group and probably would have
died alone.
Right.
Or if he was really nasty, he would have been
executed by the group.
So we know this from studies from nomadic
hunter gatherer tribes around the globe, that
being friendly, being humble was really a
prerequisite if you wanted to survive.
Now, it's only recently in this area that
we called certain of the civilized era that
everything has changed.
And nowadays, you know, there seems to be
this process that we call survival to shameless.
Right.
Or so often, if you are shameless, that can
actually be an advantage, which is, I think,
highly a natural for us as a species.
Because, you know, one of the most fascinating
things that I discovered during my research
is that human beings are actually the only
species in the animal kingdom that blush,
you know, which is a fascinating fact that
we blush.
And for thousands of years, it was an evolutionary
advantage for us because it helped us to cooperate.
And I think we need to go back to that vision
of human nature.
So I want to ask about what your vision of
human nature would imply.
Maybe the economic system should be.
But before we get to that, the Viniar theory,
is it too early to see if or how that applies
to the world reaction to Corona virus?
Or do you have some sense of if and how that
applies to how we're currently seeing the
world react to that pandemic?
Mm hmm.
Well, obviously, at first there were some
stories or quite a lot of stories in the press
about people hoarding toilet paper and, you
know, even fighting over toilet paper.
And again, it was very tempting to conclude
that, oh, here we have a crisis.
People are selfish once again.
I think by now we can zoom out and say that
actually the vast majority of most people
has actually been pro-social in nature.
Most people are actually helping each other.
There's quite some evidence accumulating now
from different countries is that, you know,
it mostly brings out the positive, the good.
And people you know, there is so many initiatives
from the bottom up, you know, groups on WhatsApp,
on Facebook and neighbors helping each other,
et cetera, et cetera.
And this is all not very surprising to sociologists,
because, as I said, you know, they've known
for a very long time that most people put
together during a time of crisis.
It's not it's not what the Hollywood movies
have told you.
You know, it's not like panic and everyone
going nuts and crazy.
Flobots very much the opposite.
You know, one of the most striking eyewitness
accounts that I discovered during my research
was, for example, how some people behaved
during 9/11, you know, when they were going
down the stairs of the Twin Tower, Twin Towers
as they were burning.
And people were literally saying, no, you
go first.
Now you go for it.
Now this is crazy, but it actually happened.
So you talked about how seeing human nature
as fundamentally greedy implies or maybe justifies
the neoliberal economic framework, which is
very interesting if someone were to accept
your fundamental view of human nature.
What is the economic system that would logically
follow from that?
Hmm.
Well, you could do a lot of things.
Actually, I started writing this book because
I had first written a book about the idea
of giving everyone a guaranteed basic income.
Right.
So this was utopia free of this.
And the book was full of studies and examples
and experiments that showed that this could
actually work.
People in general have sort of two objections
against the idea.
And they say, well, it doesn't work because,
you know, people are lazy and they'll stop
working or they'll say you can't do it because
people will waste the money.
You know, they'll just spend it on drugs or
alcohol.
They're like the two most common objections.
And so I sort of tried to collect all this
evidence and say, you know, it actually does
work.
We have tried it.
And the the science says it works.
So I went on a book tour and a couple of countries
and again and again and again, I found myself
discussing human nature with people because
Selma so often people would say, yeah, OK,
maybe this works on a local level, maybe this
works in this particular experiment here or
there in Canada or in the US in the 70s.
But that was a very different place, highly
exceptional.
In the end, you just got to look at human
nature and be realistic.
So I started to understand that for so many
of the exciting ideas that I cared about and
not only basic income, but also, for example,
different ways to do democracy, you know,
participatory democracy.
They all presuppose a different view, a more
hopeful view of human nature.
And then I realized that actually I didn't
have that view myself.
You know, I studied history.
I had, you know, studied so many of these
sort of cynical experiments from the 60s,
the Stanford Prison Experiment or the Milgram
experiment that many people will know with
a shock machine.
So I started basically on a journey with basically
to see if I if I.
Could actually realistically adopt a more
hopeful view of human nature.
And that resulted in this book.
And is there a specific I mean, from the point
of view of the vast majority of so-called
Western democracies, or is there a low hanging
fruit or so-called specific policies that
would be the ones that most obviously could
be changed for the betterment of society on
the basis of your newfound optimism?
Well, maybe it's interesting to zoom in on
prisons, which is one of the most radical
applications of this theory of human nature.
If you go to Norway, you'll find prisons that
are really, really weird and strange where
they really treat inmates as if they're actually
people.
So they're prisons like Bus Stoya or Hilborn,
very close to Oslo, where you'll find, you
know, people have been convicted of murders
or rapes or pretty horrible things, but still
get the freedom, you know, to read books.
There there's a cinema, there's even a music
studio.
They have their own music label that is called
Criminal Records.
And and you would you know, some people would
say, well, this is like some kind of holiday
resort.
But then you look at the science behind it.
Right.
You look at the statistics and in particular,
you look at the recidivism rate and you realize
that actually Norway has the lowest recidivism
rate in the world.
So the chance that someone will commit another
crime, you know, after he or she gets out
of prison, that's the recidivism rate is nowhere
as low as in Norway.
So these prisons work even though they don't
really look like prisons, they're highly,
highly effective.
Then you look at prisons in the US and you
realize that actually these prisons have have
the highest recidivism rate in the world.
Right.
If you treat people like crap, they'll will
be crap.
I think I can't make it easier than that.
If you treat people like people, they will
behave like people.
This in the case of prisons, it really goes
against your intuition, right?
You really sort of the intuition says vengeance.
You know, people have done these horrible
things.
You want vengeance.
You want to lock them up.
You want them to suffer.
But if you realistically look at what works,
then I think Norway really leads the way here.
Yeah.
It's also counterintuitive when one might
imagine you want prison to be really bad.
So people are more incentivized to avoid going
back.
And it just does not seem to actually function
function in that way, obviously.
And the other problem is that prisons can
become sort of universities for crime.
So this is really the case in the US people.
People come in maybe for small minor offenses,
drug offenses or something like that, and
then they become hardened criminals in the
prison system.
Right.
I for the book, I looked at the history of
the of of the system in the US.
And it's really astonishing to find out that
actually in the early 70s, you know, the US
experimented with Norway style prisons, you
know, and it worked really well.
It's just that after that, history took a
different direction.
Same is true for basic income.
By the way, the U.S. almost implemented a
guaranteed basic income under Nixon.
You know, there's no country that came as
close to implementing a basic income as the
U.S., but that didn't happen in the end.
No, it did because of a lot of bizarre coincidences.
Yeah, even I mean, between World War 1 and
2, there was a moment where the direction
for health care in the United States was going
towards universal health care.
But it was deemed to be too much like what
was happening in Germany at the time and for
political reasons that it was not pursued,
as we of course, of course, now know.
We've been speaking with Rutger Bregman, historian,
author of Human kind of Hopeful History and
of course, author of the bestselling Utopia
for Realists.
I so appreciate your time today.
Thank you.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dadgum.